Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'hotel F1
Non pas parce que les chambres sont à 37 euros
Mais pour une autre raison
On est à Roquebrune-sur-Argens
Exactement à l'endroit ou a disparu le triment célèbre Xavier Dupont de Ligonnes
Nous sommes là 10 ans après le meurtre de sa famille et sa disparition
Et l'idée aujourd'hui est de sonder les points d'eau de la ville
Qui n'ont pas vraiment été fouillés d'après nos recherches
On a déjà repéré deux endroits sur la carte
Et on va aller vérifier avec vous
Et, qu'est-ce qu'on cherche ?
on cherche sa carabine en calibre 22lr
Elle était aussi pourvue d'un silencieux, qui a peut-être été séparé
On cherche également son ordinateur portable qu'il a utilisé dans cet hôtel
le soir avant sa disparition
Et son téléphone portable
Pas mal de choses différentes à trouver
Bien sûr la zone a été fouillée de fond en comble
Et il a été vu sur les caméras de surveillance avec ces objets là
Il avait aussi un sac à dos et a envoyé un dernier email avant de disparaître
Il y a donc beaucoup de chance qu'il soit venu ici avec tous ces objets
On peut ici apercevoir le fameux rocher
Ici de nombreuses recherches ont été effectuées dans les grottes pour retrouver le corps de Xavier Dupont de Ligones
Sans succès
Voici donc le premier pont que nous allons sonder
C'est pas très profond regardez
Effectivement le bord n'est pas très profond
On va aller sur la plateforme ici pour pêcher à l'aimant au milieu du pont
Bon c'est l'hiver, on va se geler les jambes au moins
C'est glacé ?
Il faut y aller, il faut y aller
Il y a une pince là, ça a peut-être déjà été prospecté
Allez Rasta c'est ton tour
Allez viens
Oui on le sait qu'elle est glacée
Allez viens viens
En vrai tu peux rester si tu veux, mais à un moment il va falloir traverser
Allez Rasta on se motive
On l'a fait Rasta
Bon c'est parti pour le premier lancer
Woaw
Il y a une certaine profondeur en réalité
Allez viens
Viens vite Rasta
C'est bien, allez
Bon ça va
Le bord est peu aimanté ça va
C'est une douille de serrage
Allez c'est bien
C'est bien, il va se secouer maintenant
C'est bien !
Je ne sais pas si il va aimer cet endroit
Il n'y a pas grand chose
Bon là il y a un gros truc
Alors
est-ce que ce serait pas Ligonnes en entier qui s'est lesté ?
C'est pas impossible parce que c'est lourd
C'est un coffre fort on dirait
Oh il est fermé
D'accord
c'est un coffre fort quand même
Est-ce que Ligonnes avait un coffre fort ?
Il est fermé
On l'ouvrira à la maison
De toute façon on a pas les outils
On l'ouvre à la fin
Oui on l'ouvre à la fin, bon nous ne sommes pas venus pour ça
ça me fait délirer ce code
C'est un faux
Non c'est un vrai
Ouais c'est un vrai, un électronique
Ok c'est pas très vieux
C'est peut-être un coffre fort de chambre d'hôtel
Mais c'est marrant qu'il soit fermé
ouais
Ils l'ont sûrement refermé
oui oui
Je vide l'eau
Il n'a pas été forcé
Bon nous ne sommes pas là pour ça
Enfin on ne sait jamais
je ne sais pas s'il y a un coffre fort dans cette histoire
Trouvaille intéressante, ce trousseau de clefs bien remplis
Il y en a des tonnes, c'est un trousseau de gardien de prison ou quoi ? ahaha
C'est étonnant cette quantité
Il y en a qui sont cuivrées
Vu l'état, ça peut facilement avoir 10 ans ça
Garde les de côté on ne sait jamais
On va étudier ça
Rasta t'es tout sale
Oui moi aussi je suis sale t'as raison
Non arrête
Rasa...
J'ai déjà vu plein de fois des américains pêcher comme ça sur des lacs
Ils pêchent trois visses en général
On ne sait jamais
Entre les deux pontons, le gars peut faire tomber son portable
Franchement, bonne chance pour le récupérer
Elle est énorme la barre
D'accord, bravo
Sympa
J'ai une idée, et si je partais en exploration sur le bateau
J'y vais, je me sert de ça comme rame
Si je ne suis pas accroché, je vais aller loin
C'est attaché au sol, ne t'inquiètes pas
Imagines que tu ne peux pas me tirer
Comment tu veux que je te tire ?
Non mais je ne vais pas nager
Elle est trop froide
Il va revenir tout seul
On est en Décembre
Attend, il y a un câble ici
Allé, bonne journée
Non, non, non
Attend ! Ne tires pas
C'est bon, je reviens
Heureusement que je suis habitué à la Pêche à l'aimant
C'est vraiment jolie ici pour faire de la pêche à l'aimant les gars
Avec les petits pontons
Après c'est sûr, ce n'est pas les endroits où il y a le plus de déchets
Si vous pouvez nous relâcher un peu de ferraille
Oh ! Là oui
J'ai un truc
C'est un pied de parasole, non ?
C'est sympa
Non, c'est nul
Mais non !
Je suis content, c'est déjà mieux qu'une visse
Par contre, ça me parait un peu léger pour un pied de parasole
Nous revoilà sur la piste de Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès, plus d'un an plus tard
Depuis, de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts comme on dit en pêche à l'aimant
Vous voyez, les cheveux ont pris
Ouais et on est beaucoup plus au Nord
On est pas loin de sa ville d'origine, Nantes
On est à Nantes à un endroit où son téléphone aurai borné dans la nuit qui a suivi le drame
C'est une piste qui n'a jamais été explorée car ils n'ont pas sondés le lac
Il n'y a pas eu de témoin oculaire et on commence a aussi comprendre pourquoi
C'est un très grand lac
On a suivi une piste avec une route
Elle amène jusqu'au lac, c'est possible de venir en voiture jusque ici
Mais on est confronté à plusieurs problèmes
Notamment le fait que c'est un lac
Ce n'est pas du tout abrupt, je ne pense pas qu'il les aurait jeté là
Ca n'aurait aucun sens
On va regarder là-bas, quand même
Regarde, il est en train d'abreuver sa remorque
Là aussi, ça parait compromis, c'est vraiment une plage
Pourtant, on est au bout de la route côté lac
Mais il y a très peu de profondeur et le niveau d'eau vari
Je ne le voit pas jeter ses ordinateurs là, ils auraient refait surface bien avant
Allé, on repart
Quand on secoue, il y a quand même quelque chose
On va l'ouvrir à la disqueuse
Par l'arrière
Pour cela, on a notre expert en ouverture de coffres forts, Alex
Toujours
On a essayé de regarder par le trou mais on ne voit pas assez bien
On voit que en face
Il y a une sorte de pochette
A gauche, il y a un objet en relief qui fait comme une pochette
Marteau, burin et tu l'ouvres
Baptiste, apportes le pied de biche
Est-ce vraiment une pochette ?
Attention, c'est chaud
Oh non ...
Sérieux ...
C'est abusé là, rien du tout
Bon, le coffre de Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès était vide